on voulait vous montrer un premier
échange c'était l'échange le plus
détendu entre Emmanuel Macron et Marine
Le Pen quand il se parle ils disent
qu'ils ont vieilli en 5 ans regardez si
vous le voulez bien sur la laïcité
puisque le temps prêt qu'il y a 5 ans
madame Lepers
je crois que c'est factueux je serai
très respectueux à votre égard vous ça
ne se voit pas moi j'ai peur que ça se
voit beaucoup madame
c'était sympa pour toi alors sur ça en
fait déjà ce qui est génial c'est c'est
de voir que c'est Manuel Macron du coup
qui essaye de lancer une connivence donc
de montrer que c'est pas une opposition
d'être humain mais que c'est une
opposition d'idée à ce moment-là et on
voit que Marine Le Pen elle répond tout
de suite pour pas laisser le pouvoir
parce que l'humour c'est aussi le
pouvoir bien sûr quand on fait la blague
c'est nous qui existons et elle en
faisant sa blague lui en renvoie une ça
se met à rire les deux et là on peut
voir quelque chose de très précis on
voit Emmanuel Macron qui se recule et
qui est content et qui regarde du coin
de l'oeil de on est vraiment copains là
et sur le même temps on voit Marine Le
Pen qui cherche à fuir le parce que ça
va pas la satisfaire quand même de
montrer cette connexion là qui existe à
ce moment-là donc elle file regard et
elle baisse la tête pour terminer de
rire alors quand on baisse la tête en
général c'est un symbole de honte là
elle a pas honte évidemment de faire la
blague mais ça la gêne quand même que ça
prenne une proportion si rapidement de
connexion à Michael quoi
c'est le ramadan ensemble
c'est les infos que j'ai oublié c'est
les infos que j'ai voilà moi j'ai
remarqué hier aussi vous avez vu
Emmanuel Macron il commençait
pratiquement toutes ces prises de parole
pas vous avez je suis d'accord avec vous
vous avez raison Marine Le Pen sur ce
sujet donc à chaque fois c'est vrai
qu'ils étaient renforcé par des Oui-Oui
de sa part quoi
on va on va on va faire on va voir ça je
vais vous expliquer pourquoi vous vous
trompez c'était un peu ça oui vous
voulez dire que oui non je voulais juste
te dire que certains ont quand même
analysé que cette phrase de d'Emmanuel
Macron était aussi un petit peu
potentiellement une provocation pour
dire en effet ben moi j'ai un peu
vieilli parce que j'ai travaillé dur
pendant 5 ans donc il y a eu quelques
analystes politiques qui ont eu cette
réflexion moi personnellement
moi je traite toujours de du non-verbal
c'est à dire la forme uniquement le fond
ma foi il y a plein de gens pour bien
trouver des théories sur ça j'y crois
pas un enfant
c'est normal il va pas lui dire
après et après bon ça part en plein
milieu du débat justement Emmanuel
Macron évoqué la relation de Marine Le
Pen avec Vladimir Poutine il a accusé
d'être son banquier vous allez nous dire
ce que vous voyez dans cet échange
regarde avec contracté un prêt en 2015
auprès d'une banque russe la First shake
Russian Bank proche du pouvoir en
septembre 2014 et donc vous ne parlez
pas à d'autres dirigeants vous parlez à
votre banquier quand vous parlez de la
Russie c'est ça le problème Madame Le
Pen et ça n'est pas un hasard si il y a
5 ans la Russie était intervenue dans la
campagne ce qui a été prouvé au mode
déstabiliser
et si vous avez toujours été ambigu sur
le sujet
alors on est sur quelque chose de très
primaire en fait on pourrait l'analyser
comme ça c'est toujours subjectif
attention à une analyse quand même bien
sûr mais là ce qui est intéressant c'est
que au début Emmanuel Macron se recule
c'est à dire il prend toute sa place lui
qui a été beaucoup comme ça durant tout
le débat pour envoyer sa punch
évidemment que Marine Le Pen allait
préparer une casserole donc elle sait
très bien que ça va sortir un moment
donné donc elle elle s'encre dans le sol
c'est comme elle peut pas le faire avec
ses pieds là avec ses bras et elle
regarde vraiment fixement pour elle
montrer à ce moment-là elle a conscience
de son non verbal et elle sait qu'elle
ne doit rien trahir ni de son agacement
ni de son énervement donc elle reçoit
elle prépare le nom de la tête elle est
prête à riposter et c'est pour ça
qu'elle est avancer à ce moment là et
comme Emmanuel Macron le ressent c'est
pour ça que lui bah ça prochaine mais
d'une autre manière plus détendu qu'un
truc un peu par terre analyste de c'est
pas grave mais je t'explique c'est ça
qui va se passer à ce moment-là
est-ce que c'est pas une erreur de sa
part justement ce nom de la tête parce
que avant de le formuler je trouve que
elle a l'air presque de lui obéir de se
soumettre et de pas répondre le de la
tête je trouve que pour elle il est
cruel c'est quelque chose qu'on a quand
même beaucoup vu sur ce débat ils se
sont assez peu coupés l'un l'autre en
fait il y avait un espèce de respect de
ce côté là c'est c'était un débat un
petit peu à l'ancienne un Marine Le Pen
à la choisit une posture moi qui me
rappelle 64 81 88 je suis présidentiable
je suis digne je suis quelqu'un qui ne
coupe pas la parole qui se polie et qui
sait faire donc je pense c'est pour ça
qu'elle a fait ça en cohérence à ce
moment-là alors il y a un autre moment
où vous voulez montrer leur sous-marine
Le Pen a évoqué le bilan économique
d'Emmanuel Macron et là aussi elle n'est
pas allé de ma mort regarde
attends monsieur Macron mais je rappelle
que vous êtes le président qui a créé
600 milliards d'euros de dettes
supplémentaires en 5 ans dont deux tiers
qui n'ont rien à voir avec le
covides
non strictement rien à voir ce sont les
chiffres d'ailleurs de vos propres
ministères qui évoquent 145 milliards
pour le covid tout le reste se c'est de
la gravation de la dette
mais arrêtez de tout confondre c'est pas
possible ne me donnez pas de leçons
de mon projet mais c'est tout le temps à
600 milliards d'euros de dettes
qui contient une énorme colère en fait
en réalité on voit alors bon au départ
il encaisse après il se rapproche pour
essayer de faire cette même stratégie
depuis le départ et là on va voir qui
commence à dilater les narines à quand
on dilate les narines c'est pas bon
quelqu'un qui n'a rien et qui vous
propose de boire un verre après non
ici
[Rires]
on voit aussi une crispation au niveau
de la mâchoire on voit les deux sorciers
10 ans ça se rapprocher on voit après
qui se lèche l'élève pour se les
humidifier parce que il a une sécheresse
juste là d'un coup donc il est en train
de tout contenir et il dégluti en
soufflant on l'entend très précisément
en train de faire comme ça un truc comme
ça parce que il essaie de tout garder
parce que ça par contre ça pourrait le
faire sortir et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
qui va utiliser l'ironie par derrière
c'est c'est un peu comme une
cocotte-minute c'est ça soupape de
décompression mais à ce moment là ça
l'énerve grave il se dit ah faut pas que
je tombe là dedans alors bébé ça vous
plaire bébé quand je quand je non
pas mal au poker prenez des cours ah oui
et notamment oui parce que j'avais bien
avec un comportementaliste comme vous
sur le le langage et il me disait que
quelqu'un qui pense à deux cartes comme
ça si ils s'avance vers la table au
moment de miser du jeu exactement c'est
qu'il est sûr de lui qu'il a du jeu qui
va être agressif parce qu'il est sûr de
ce qu'il va dire si vraiment je suis
français carte et hop avant de miser
recule un petit peu il est sur la
défense
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors les candidats ont ensuite évoqué
l'Europe de penser des vérités les
candidats ont ensuite évoqué l'Europe un
sujet qui divise beaucoup les deux
candidats regardez et faites bien
attention à leur gestuelle là-dessus
ce projet quand on remet bric-à-brique
des choses en place c'est un projet qui
ne dit pas son nom mais qui consiste à
faire sortir de l'Europe des nations oui
mais enfin si c'est que l'Union
européenne vous sortez de l'Union
européenne même Le Pen non mais pardon
de vous le dire on peut on peut décider
de ripoliner tout seul la façade mais
enfin c'est pas c'est une copropriété
aucun moment donné dans une copropriété
vous pouvez pas dire du jour au
lendemain ça s'appelle plus la
copropriété ça s'appelle comme j'ai
décidé parce que je m'appelle Madame Le
Pen
alors moi je pense qu'à une personne est
vraiment j'y pense du fond du coeur
c'est la personne qui traduit en langage
des finances comment il a fait pour
ripoliner
il utilise les punchlines habituel là ce
qui était quand même par contre assez
marquant c'est juste avant d'envoyer ça
punch les deux mains qui étaient comme
ça c'est à dire que là on est plus dans
les crispations qu'ils ont depuis le
départ il était vraiment dans l'assise
de quelque chose il sait que voilà
exactement là on a des certitudes on a
quelqu'un qui sort de lui et on a
quelqu'un qui va emmener une autre
personne sur son terrain il le sait
c'est même sa meilleure attitude je
trouve en posture non-verbal de tout le
débat c'est le moment où il se sait
puissant il sait qu'il va pouvoir
l'emmener en galère d'accord alors il y
a un autre extrait qui nous intéresse si
c'est compter concernant le langage non
verbal entre les deux candidats c'est
celui où Marine Le Pen évoque très
rapidement la faire mckinssey regarde
la réforme que vous proposez est une
réforme qui consiste à payer les
professeurs en fonction des résultats de
leurs élèves je sais pas c'est McKinsey
qui a proposé ça y est je l'attendais
celle-là mais en Espagne
je pense que ça peut être ça peut être
là franchement pour le coup ça peut être
eux je trouve que c'est profondément
injuste alors c'est très mal joué c'est
très mal joué de la part de Marine Le
Pen donc elle avait prévu d'envoyer sa
petite punch sur ma kingsee c'était sûr
que ça allait sortir manuel Macron était
certainement prêt pour ça mais dans le
non-verbal ce qui nous intéresse c'est
qu'au moment d'envoyer ce petit son
petit pic déjà elle doute elle doute
tellement que à peine elle l'a envoyé
elle casse le regard elle détendent le
regard elle a du mal à déglutir à ce
moment-là et Emmanuel Macron qui est
prêt à recevoir ça et qui c'est qu'elle
est potentiellement passer armée pour
traiter dans le fond du sujet veut
justement pas la laisser en faire un pic
et dit bon vous avez vu son attitude il
y a un Nadia bah alors et ça fait
longtemps je pensais qu'on allait il
veut la forcer en parler mais elle elle
ne veut pas en parler c'est essentiel
juste une attaque gratos en fait donc
elle va commencer à bégayer elle fuit le
regard elle a ce mouvement de recul en
fait elle est allé sur un terrain
qu'elle ne voulait pas à ce moment-là et
c'est très visible de sa part alors on
va revoir maintenant les attitudes
d'Emmanuel Macron qui ont été commentés
partout sur les réseaux sociaux
Daniel ça va mourir Daniel allez Daniel
Daniel ça va madame pauliner la gorge
est-ce que c'est McKinsey je crois
qu'elle est lié à la ferme à kinshasé
également
de lui quelque chose merci non ça va ça
va bien ça va aussi les mecs être
rejoindra pas tout de suite
[Rires]
c'est la personne ça fait tard là aussi
ça fait tard les émissions
Emmanuel Macron a pu prendre pendant le
débat ont été commenté et repris sur les
réseaux regardez à la pose numéro une
c'est quoi ça
alors ça ça peut passer pour du mépris
ou de l'arrogance mais c'est
généralement la posture qu'il a adopté
durant cette soirée qui est bon moi les
gars j'étais en train de travailler en
train de travailler là je vous écoute un
petit peu mais je repars moi j'ai du
boulot ça ce petit jeu là moi je suis
sur le terrain en vrai il y a un peu
aussi vous n'êtes pas au niveau moi je
trouve que dans le regard ce que j'ai
beaucoup plus vous n'êtes pas au niveau
et je pense pas que c'est ça sonnecement
ce qu'il a voulu euh
excuse-moi toi tu t'es cromagnétique
non mais non mais c'est intéressant ce
qu'il dit non mais c'est vrai qu'il y a
des gens qui ont dit ça aussi on dirait
qu'il est atterré en fait là il a un
côté non regardez la 2 la 2 là la deux
là on dirait qu'il a atterrit sur la de
regarder voilà là il est saoulé la 2
c'est quoi déjà c'est impossible oui
c'est plus alors vous êtes pas
comportementaliste je vous rassure moi
non plus je suis justement devant ta
liste mais mais de ce côté là quand il
est comme ça en fait c'est la continuité
du truc avec juste un changement de
posture pour pour les ans on dit parfois
que quand on fait ça c'est qu'on se
referme là c'était pas le cas il
changeait juste de position par contre
le visage avec la bouche qui descend
vers le bas c'est moi je suis compétent
alors c'est pas forcément vous n'êtes
pas compétent mais moi je suis compétent
alors déblatérer mais vous ne savez pas
de quoi vous parlez parce que moi je
sais exactement de quoi servir qui est
ça fait arrogant quand même ça donne de
la revanche alors que c'est pas
tellement du mépris parce que le mépris
on le voit beaucoup avec des asymétries
sur le visage là c'est plus blasé j'ai
c'est plus j'ai pas le temps pour vos
conneries donc il ne la considère pas
comme présidentiable à ce moment là
c'est ça qui se passe c'est pas du
mépris c'est juste je suis au niveau et
il y a personne qui a mon niveau c'est
pas elle spécifiquement à ce moment
alors pour la pause de regarder la
prochaine pause
il faut il faut pas douter d'une chose
c'est que Emmanuel Macron et Marine Le
Pen sont des personnes très
intelligentes ils savent qu'il y a des
blaireaux comme moi qui viennent
analyser ensuite donc ça renvoie et à ce
moment-là c'est un calcul en fait de jeu
je l'entretien
ça ça va donner aussi le message aux
autres de dans le fond c'est pas très
passionnant ce qu'elle raconte et il
s'en fiche que je j'imagine qu'il y ait
des personnes comme nous qui qui mettons
le doigt dessus parce que dans la masse
peut-être qu'en terme de manipulation
mentale ce non verbal va rameter des
personnes à penser comme lui tu vois
alors on a on a un autre extrait
regardez celui-là
après on aura Marine Le Pen aussi non
pas celui-là le prochain
que vous pouvez donner baisser le
chômage il est passé de 9,6 à 7,4% et le
Bureau international du travail comme
son nom l'indique et l'organisme qui
fait référence
c'est quoi ça c'est pour ça c'est la
pire séduction non l'affaire c'est là où
s'arrête la compétence du analyse comme
je vous le disais d'analyse est toujours
subjectif je suis un mec de
divertissement ça n'engage que moi ce
que je dis mais quand quelqu'un fait ça
là je pourrais vous dire plein de trucs
un petit peu rigolo
[Musique]
c'est un petit peu coquin en se mordille
un petit peu le doigt il y a un petit
côté un petit peu séduction mais pour
une image comme ça il faudra avoir
l'avant après il faudra avoir du
contexte on appelle ça la base line en
mentalisme il faut savoir ce qui se
passe dedans parce que je sais même pas
qu'il regarde d'ailleurs à ce moment-là
on est d'accord que tout ça il travaille
en amont avec eux
dans les petits papiers du pouvoir une
chose est certaine du moins c'est que
ils ont tout intérêt à se faire coacher
à l'américaine on l'assume complètement
en France on l'assume moins maintenant
qu'on se fasse coacher ou pas le le
non-verbal est ce qu'il est il trahit
des choses très rapidement les micros
expressions qui qui ont lieu un quart de
seconde sur le visage on peut pas les
contrôler on peut pas les simuler ça
effectivement ça peut être simulé mais
ça peut être stimuler mais il y a pas
d'intérêt là en l'occurrence à le faire
regardez ce que fait Delormeau depuis
tout à l'heure
c'est pour ça que je surveille la main
et on va revenir maintenant sur Marine
Le Pen sur les attitudes de Marine Le
Pen une dernière d'Emmanuel Macron une
dernière pause d'Emmanuel Macron
regardez c'est celle-là qu'on avait pas
vu je voulais qu'on bon là c'est quoi
c'est ça veut dire quoi là ça dépend du
mouvement par contre on voit une action
en avant et c'est quelque chose qu'on a
beaucoup vu durant le débat il avait un
petit côté toujours en avant et qui
était un peu paternaliste c'est-à-dire
que plus baisser plus baisser en même
temps d'intonation de sa voix et il y
avait un côté un peu professoral de
c'est super votre programme mais ça
marche pas je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi donc il y avait une attitude
qui était c'est vrai pas agressive on
l'a vu ils sont pas trop agressés l'un
l'autre mais par contre lui était
vraiment de c'est gentil mais je vais
t'expliquer quand même
là on le voit encore dans la posture de
oui alors ok mais on peut faire mieux
alors il y a deux pauses qui sont
ressorties chez Marine Le Pen celle-ci
regardez celle-ci oui ok là c'est quand
même la grande détresse alors quand les
sourcils se rapprochent en général c'est
dans la micro expression de détresse de
peur ou de tristesse là on voit que
c'est un mix quand même des deux les
mains jointes c'est rarement en tout cas
un hasard alors déjà c'est qu'on veut
contrôler ses mains et on l'a vu
beaucoup chez Marine Le Pen elle
joignait les mains elle contrôler un
petit peu son langage non verbal parce
qu'elle contrôlait son attitude et quand
on place devant sa bouche c'est que on
veut s'empêcher de répondre on l'a vu
aussi chez Manuel Macron qui qui loquait
comme ça un petit peu c'est pour ça
qu'ils se sont pas trop interrompus donc
là elle fait un petit peu les deux elle
a du mal aussi à recevoir comme lui
quand il s'énervé tout à l'heure mais là
c'est quand même une autre attitude de
ok c'est pas ça du tout mais il faut
surtout pas que je l'interrompre parce
que je veux garder mes temps de parole
propre comme je l'ai décidé
quoi Macron à faire un moment donné un
truc à la Mitterrand comme ça là
ce que faisait Mitterrand pendant les
débat c'est quoi ça alors ça je l'ai pas
et je l'ai pas vu je l'ai pas vu
comme ça
le gratouille ça c'est plutôt un truc
qu'on fait pour se rassurer soi-même
mais il faut être un peu sûr de soi
quand même pour oser
histoire de positionnement parce que
sinon pour se rassurant on va plutôt
faire comme Marine Le Pen faisait
c'est-à-dire bien serré et puis elle
s'était intéressante parce que des fois
plus ça blanchissait au niveau de des
articulations des doigts plus tu sentais
que si elle se lâchait elle aurait dit
des choses un peu différemment et un peu
différente alors on a une autre regardez
une autre attitude de Marine Le Pen
regardez
oui oui là le stop elle met la leçon
alors évidemment je commente j'ouvre
j'enfonce des portes ouvertes parce que
on le voit c'est très clair ça me
rappelle une autre gestuelle qu'elle a
eu aussi un moment donné les gestes
courtes c'est ça qui m'intéresse le plus
à un moment donné elle lui avait dit
quelque chose aussi et puis elle a fait
aller comme ça juste les deux mains
comme ça c'est à dire que pas mal de
fois son corps envoyait de attention et
arrêtez
là en non-verbal elle l'a beaucoup
briquet elle l'a beaucoup arrêté plus
que verbalement ce qui est complètement
différent de ce qui s'est passé en 2017
et là pour le coup ça montre un travail
de coaching et de réflexion en amont
alors justement on aura son coach celui
qui la coaché dans un instant Laurent
jacobelli porte-parole de Marine Le Pen
qui sera avec nous pour dire comment il
a coaché avant le débat ça ça va être
assez intéressant également on aura
Florian seniki aussi spécialiste en
communication politique qui sera avec
nous et edwardo riancipel porte-parole
des territoires des progrès et de la
campagne d'Emmanuel Macron qui me dira
lui aussi comment il s'est coacher et on
viendra aussi sur ce qui a été dit qui
avait tort qui avait raison parce qu'il
y a des chiffres tout on reviendra sur
tout pour vous dire voilà ça c'est
Emmanuel Macron qui a raison ça c'est
Marine Le Pen donc on verra ça dans
quelques instants regardez la revue
tweet sur l'attitude d'Emmanuel Macron
parce que il y en a eu pas mal regardez
il y a victoire qui dit une question aux
électeurs de Macron est-ce que ça vous
fait de voir votre candidat se tenir
comme ça j'ai posé ma question poliment
je vous demande de rester poli en retour
merci qu'est-ce que vous disiez
qu'est-ce que c'est
pour moi c'est un mauvais calcul mais
encore une fois on m'a pas demandé mon
avis donc ça tombe bien pardon vous êtes
cette gentillesse là mais mais c'est un
mauvais calcul parce que évidemment ça
envoie des signaux et et certains
signaux que vous avez peut-être pas
perçu qui qui sont des points référents
comme l'appel polkman qui a fait des
grands travaux là-dessus c'est-à-dire
que il y a des gestes qui sont rarement
fait par hasard et ce geste là si
j'enlève ma tête et que je monte un peu
ben ça fait un bras d'honneur en fait
donc c'est pas très bon sur ce que ça
envoie il faut faire très attention à ça
vous savez quand quelqu'un se gratte
avec le majeur et uniquement le majeur
pour mettre les lunettes ou se gratter
c'est rarement un hasard dans la
conversation parce que le
le cerveau fait son travail inconscient
aussi et ce sont des emblèmes un petit
peu
mais alors là c'était contrebalancer
avec le petit regard ça n'est pas pour
vous ça n'est pas bon regardez alors
mais est-ce que moi je regardais il y a
un autre tweet voilà qui était voilà
le téléphone
à la main écrasé de comme ça tout à
l'heure ça on voit quand même un message
de regarder je ne dis rien de méchant
mais c'est tellement inintéressant
Emmanuel Macron disait le match est
facile est-ce que c'est ça ou pas je
pense que dans ce qu'il cherche à
envoyer c'est encore une fois pas
forcément lui qui pense que le match est
facile parce que encore une fois je lui
prête une forme intelligence à Emmanuel
Macron comme Amagne Le Pen de bien
savoir ce que ça envoie ce genre de
choses et donc c'est plus l'envie
d'envoyer regardez c'est pas très
intéressant c'est vraiment pas très
intéressant et c'est une forme
d'agressivité passive c'est encore une
fois ce débat était assez mou il y a
assez peu de choses à commencer mine de
rien c'est moins dense qu'en 2017 et lui
a choisi cette posture là de je vais
faire de l'agressivité mais secondaire
en fait en envoyant le fait que c'est
pas un bon propos ce que vous est-ce que
vous envoyez et je vais pas perdre
d'énergie à vous contredire je vais vous
laisser écouter parler comme ça